so we're once again in the middle of a
climate change summit and as is often
the case during these climate change
summits we are starting to see articles
uh outraged um about the fact that many
world leaders and others like jeff bezos
flew to in this case it's glasgow
scotland to the climate change summit on
private jets and the contrast that is
illuminated by these articles is of
course about we're trying to figure out
climate change and yet private jet on a
per person basis
outrageous carbon footprint a private
jet where you might have two pilots and
a flight attendant and two people or you
know maybe a small entourage
on a per-person basis an outrageous
uh expenditure of carbon emissions and
um it is something that happens every
time there is one of these climate
summits and it's an issue and i'm going
to talk about it but i actually believe
that it's part of the distraction from
the real issue and i'll explain to you
in a moment so here's just one sample
article
around 400 private jets
carrying heads of state billionaires
business leaders and celebrities have
converged on glasgow for a global
warming summit amazon founder jeff
bezos's 65 million us dollar gulf stream
jet was among the hundreds of vip jets
reportedly carrying more than a thousand
attendees and their staff to the cop26
meeting cop26 with others including
microsoft founder bill gates actor
arnold schwarzenegger also expected to
fly in
it can't be stressed enough how bad
private jets are for the environment it
is the worst way to travel by miles says
matt finch from the uk's transport and
environment campaign group the average
private jet and we are not talking air
force one emits two tons of co2 every
hour in flight private jets are very
prestigious but it is difficult to avoid
the hypocrisy of using one while
claiming to be fighting climate change
he said for context the total carbon
footprint of an ordinary citizen
including everywhere they travel and
everything they consume is around eight
tons a year so basically like just your
flight to cop26 is two tons
per hour per hour
and um most normal people um consume you
know about eight tons a year in carbon
emissions in total the 400 private
aircraft are expected to emit 13 000
tons of carbon dioxide but uk secretary
of state liz trust defended the number
of planes flying in saying it's
important that we have people face to
face i think everybody who's ever done a
zoom call knows they're quite useful for
some things but when you really get into
crunch negotiations when you want to
look somebody in the eye and talk to
them face to face you do need to meet in
person so
listen um i i hate to tell people
the solution is not going to be to ban
private jets
so let's take it piece by piece
does this happen at every climate change
summit yes do people get angry every
time yes is there something legitimately
hypocritical about saying we want to
deal with climate but i'm going to
expend
a family's worth of annual co2 emissions
just to fly myself in this case to
glasgow scotland yes that that's all
absolutely true and legitimate but
there's two different things that are
going on here first is just a kind of
like a pragmatism
um the
economics of private jets for these
elites for lack of a better term
um dignitaries billionaires politicians
etc the economics of the private jet
makes sense and it's been calculated uh
ad nauseam if you're a ceo and you've
got to go to the airport uh typically
the airports you fly out of commercially
are far more congested and in traffic
laden areas and you've got to get there
an hour and a half before the flight or
maybe longer depending on what's going
on um and then you've got to do security
boarding all these different things then
get out of the airport just the
additional time
on the basis of of what ceos get paid
makes it worth it to do the private jet
now you could say well they shouldn't be
getting paid that much okay these are
all debates we can have but i want to
first start from just like a completely
pragmatic thing the private jets aren't
going away for these people private jets
aren't going to be banned i don't even
know what the
legal framework would be to ban private
jets like this just this stuff just
isn't going to happen we might want to
do some of these things it's not going
to happen so the solution here is not
going to be to ban private jets all
right that's number one in terms of like
the technological question here the
solution on private jet emissions is
going to be renewable fuels
solar-powered planes prototypes already
exist at some point it's going to be a
real thing we have to be realistic as
far as that goes i am 110 on board
in saying look at the per person carbon
emissions for getting these people to
glasgow it's obscene it's crazy it's
particularly counterproductive when
we're talking about dealing with climate
fine but it's not going to change
now
um
the more important thing
is
for me the private jet thing
is
almost as big of a distraction as saying
you should recycle
your orange juice
containers
and the boxes your amazon stuff comes in
and stop using plastic straws as a look
away from the real problem issue which
is 100 companies are responsible for 71
of global emissions and you not using
plastic straws is not really going to
change that reminder
the guardian's been on this for four
years
100 companies are responsible for 71 of
global emissions a relatively small
number of fossil fuel producers and
their investors could hold the key to
tackling climate change just 100
companies have been the source of more
than 70 percent of the world's
greenhouse gas emissions since 1988 the
carbon majors report pinpoints how a
relatively small set of fossil fuel
producers may hold the key to systemic
change on carbon emissions we've known
this for a very long time
even commercial air travel
accounts for only three to four percent
of total
u.s greenhouse gas emissions so
here we're talking about private jets
private jets are a smaller emitter of
carbon emissions than the commercial
airline industry commercial airliners
are responsible for three to four
percent of u.s greenhouse gas emissions
the private jets are a fraction of that
so the finger pointing at the jets and
the air travel
for me
is almost the same distraction as saying
you're not did you just throw out
that paper bag instead of recycling it
or reusing it the biggest polluters are
thrilled to have articles about plastic
straws
they're thrilled to have articles about
people are trashing half of what they
could be recycling and they're almost as
thrilled to have articles about look at
the private jets being sent to glasgow
are the optics bad of course
of course they're bad but the private
jets aren't going away they can
eventually be shifted to renewable
sources of energy we already have the
prototypes it's going to be a while and
it is another one of these distractions
from the fact that unregulated or barely
regulated or not enough regulated major
industry has not been told by
governments
you're not going to be able to keep
polluting in this way 100 companies 71
of global emissions so i'm not laughing
off the private jet thing but it's
important to contextualize it lastly
i also don't care that much about the
private jets
if really substantive change comes from
the talks which it rarely does
often these talks are we all agree very
seriously very strongly that climate
change is a problem
let's set
vague
maybe achievable completely
unenforceable goals
and end up putting barely a dent in the
greenhouse gas emissions that we're
pumping into the atmosphere so
i really wouldn't care about the private
jets if we had something enforceable and
more serious come out of these talks the
the cycle is likely to continue
it's not actually because of the private
jets the private jets to me are more of
a sign of the gap between rich and poor
some people can't afford 400 a month for
rent and meanwhile you have people
flying to glasgow for the climate change
talks spending 500 or a thousand or two
thousand dollars an hour in gas alone
for the private jet never mind the
pilots
and the uh airport fees and all these
different things so yes it's absurd but
let's contextualize the absurdity if you
disagree with me let me know let's be
honest most health food snacks are not
very exciting they don't taste great
they don't fill you up one of our
sponsors is monk pack who makes amazing
keto granola bars that are sweet soft
chewy and filling with a slight crunch
each has only one gram of sugar two to
three net carbs and just 140 calories
perfect for anybody doing low carb or
keto or if you just want a tasty sweet
snack without the sugar
everybody should be mindful of sugar
intake but you don't have to do so at
the expense of flavor because monk pack
keto granola bars come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip peanut
butter blueberry almond vanilla there
are other flavors too i can tell you
first hand they're all great i always
keep these in my pantry it's a perfect
snack during a busy day go to
monkpack.com
link underneath this video and you'll
save 20 when you use the promo code
pacman at checkout